-Today is Friday, guys,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox.
I return some emails.
And of course,
I send out thank you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running
a bit behind today,
so I thought, if you guys
wouldn't mind, I'd like to
write out my weekly
thank you notes right now.
Is that okay?
[ Applause ]
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Gentle piano music playing ]
-Ahh.
He's in a good mood for once.
-Wow.
-That's the first time I've ever
seen him smile in my life.
-Yeah.
[ Piano music continues ]
-"Thank you leaf blowers
for just making my leaves
someone else's problem."
[ Applause ]
"You deal with it."
-"Get out of the yard!"
-I don't like the way it looks,
so I'm gonna put it
on your property.
-Can you throw these away
for me?
-I do like
those Halloween garbage bags
that were a hit
a couple of years ago.
-Oh, that you put the leaves in?
-Yeah.
Some bags of garbage.
Oh.
"Thank you to
Facebook going down,
for making it impossible to tell
my friend's sister's
college roommate's mother-in-law
that I liked her hat."
[ Applause ]
Cool hat.
"Thank you, 'Squid Game' guards
for showing me
what it would look like
if a human
PlayStation controller
was trying to kill me."
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-"Thank you
teaser trailer for
the new Adele song
for giving everyone a chance
to schedule their emotional
health days ahead of time."
It's gonna be good.
I know. I could already feel it.
I got the feels.
I got the feels, man.
"Thank you, new Eggo
waffle-flavored Pop Tarts,
and if toasted
breakfast-flavored
toasted breakfast sounds good,
make sure you check out
beer-flavored Budweiser."
Tastes like beer.
-Yeah!
-Yeah.
-Coors-flavored Budweiser.
-"Thank you, scarecrows,
for always looking like
you're doing a spooky
'Titanic' reenactment."
[ Laughter ]
-Two "Titanic" references.
-Two of them, man.
-Hot topic. Everyone's
talking about "Titanic."
-Topical.
-"Thank you, aftershave,
for including the directions
right in your name."
[ Applause ]
-Wait, before?
-Before?
-"Thank you, baseball umpires,
for always looking like
you're mid-twerk."
There you have it, everybody.
Those were my thank you notes!